[Music]
do you ever think there could be a
Rascal Flatts reunion
yeah you know I don't know I have no
idea I really I haven't talked to the
guys but I know there's no talk stuff
but now but but never say never Well for
now the multi-platinum singer is
focusing on his own solo career
releasing The Anthem get down like that
so let's show you how to get down like
that and lending a hand on the writing
is fellow country star Thomas Rhett who
would you love to collaborate with who's
on like the list for you as a solo
artist you know I'd love to collab with
Adele or yes uh hey
um those are really good so who had the
best reaction to hearing this song for
the first time in your life probably my
mom because I played it for she was like
who is that it was just it's a different
part in my voice that she hadn't heard
before I was like that's me ma it's like
what
okay so finish this sentence for me Gary
levox gets down by doing the kick worm
wait is that the dance move yeah yeah
yeah the dance move you can do that I I
used to be able to now if I get down
like that I have to get somebody to help
me get up like that